so
[Music]
at least
those of you that are with us online we
want to welcome you tonight
with us and
believe you're in a place of blessing
you believe you're in a place of
blessing
right
all right
we can hear you loud and clear in our
ears if that helps anything
uh
and then additionally we have other
meetups a number of other meetups that
connect throughout the week
if you need a youth group rather to help
you
grow grow closer to god and to others
and please fill out a card at the small
table in the hallway after the service
and i want to say now to this the cards
that are out there on the table are
pleasant valleys cars but we're going to
use them
so just cross out pleasant valley you
know fill out your the car and we'll ask
you again talk to you as a visitor at
the end uh but those are pleasant valley
cards so use those cards and uh make
your requests known have not because you
ask not
all right now we're going to just uh
prepare ourselves for worship so let's
uh stand up and let's pray together
let's stand to our feet and pray
together amen
thank you lord
father it's an awesome opportunity that
we have that we can draw together and
just lift up our praise praise from our
hearts and say thank you to you to be
grateful unto you for all that you've
done
for all mankind we just love you so much
and as we enter into this time of vocal
praise father we just invite you to hear
our praise to enjoy our praise and to
just be present in the hearts and
thoughts of everyone here in jesus name
amen
thanks mike
i love hearing other people's voices in
our community come up and share things
and be a part of different aspects of
the service it just touches my heart so
much because that's what a church is
right it's not the service it's the
people and i just
i just love it every time you guys are
bold enough to come and share your voice
and your words with us thank you so much
um
well we're going to get started josh is
going to kick us off with i will not
forget you and i just want to invite all
of you guys to come into this space
this song to me rings out gratitude so i
hope that we can enter in grateful for
what we have even amidst the different
struggles and burdens that we all carry
um let's take this time together to
remember the things that
god has given us and
and be grateful to him and
enjoy this space um and the room that
he's created for each one of us here all
right
josh whenever you're ready
[Music]
many men
will
drink the rain
turn to thank the clouds
many men
will hear you speak they will never
turn around
i will not forget you
you are my god
[Music]
in my sacrifices
a faithful prayer
already
let me
shines
they will never change their minds
i will not forget you
you are my god
in my sacrifices
myself
a
a huge of grace
[Applause]
but i will not forget you
you are my god my king
and with a faithful heart
[Music]
give
to
you
[Music]
i search the world
[Applause]
[Music]
treasures that fade are never enough
every
there's nothing
better than
nothing is
i'm not afraid
to show you my weakness
my failure is
me again
is
nothing is better
you turn
you turn shame into glory
you're the only
voices
nothing is
is
[Music]
you're the only one who cares
you turn graves into
you're the only one who
you're the only one who cares
you're the only one
there's nothing
better than you
better than you oh there's nothing
nothing is better than you
let's just sing that one more time
together
god there's nothing
better
[Music]
nothing is better than you
would you guys join us in our prayers of
the people and if you're online please
feel free to comment as we share
a name or situation that you're carrying
on your heart and we lift those up to
god together
jesus for the city of saxi texas and for
every city and community and all of
those who live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
for the old and the sick and the widow
and the orphan
for the injured and the suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute
for prisoners and captives and for all
who remember and care for them
we pray to you
lord we know that you love us
and that you hear us
and so now we lift these names and
situations
up to you
from online please pray for the more
family
for angelina spears
from online please pray
for nancy
johnny owen
[Music]
god for these names and moments that
we've spoken aloud and for those that
we've kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence
amen
[Music]
so
worthy of every song we could ever see
worthy of all the praise we could ever
bring
worthy of every breath we could ever
breathe
[Music]
jesus the name above every other name
jesus
there is
with your heart and lead me
worthy
worthy of every song we could ever sing
worthy of all the praise we could ever
bring
worthy of every
[Music]
jesus
and
holy there is no one like you
there is none beside you
open up my eyes
who you are
with your heart and lead me
[Music]
i
will build my life
and
it is
and i will
there is no one like you
there is none beside you
open up my
with your heart and lead me
in your love
[Music]
yes god
would you keep leading us
in your love
would you keep showing us the path of
jesus
direct our feet towards it god
would our hands be your hands in this
world
would our words be your words of life
and restoration to those around us
would we believe
for something better
[Applause]
god would we call out the good
would we be examples of jesus on this
earth
thank you for who you are thank you god
that you are the one who can save
you are the one that we give all our
praise to
you are the one above all else
you are the name above every other name
and that's why we gather in this place
that's why we come each sunday and lift
our voices together
not to put on a production
not to entertain one another but to join
our voices in a chorus of belief that
you are good that you are with us that
you are transforming us that you are
bringing about your work in this world
thank god would we be a part of that
would we jump into where you are
would your nature and your character
flood our lives
where we're short-tempered and selfish
god would you be the balm of love
and graciousness and forgiveness god
where we run out of patience would you
come and saturate us
with your peace
we need it so badly
[Music]
thank you for being for us and for our
good
we love you jesus and we are grateful
for this time together it's in your name
that we lift up all these things and
pray blessings over every person in this
room
in jesus name
amen
thank you guys we all sit and turn to
the people around you and just make them
feel welcomed and at home as brett comes
up to give our message
well good evening everyone
grace and peace
my name is brett i'm the pastor here and
uh it's really good to to be with each
and every one of you tonight
um i want to also welcome those joining
us online
love you all lots i got a number of
texts this week um with folks that i
know are are there online so um it's
good to connect with you in this in this
way um and also anyone who's new thank
you so much for um just being with us i
know it can can be a bit intimidating to
come into a new space so thank you for
being here tonight um
so any of you are y'all new year's
resolution people
anyone
into such yeah i see a few that's
awesome i'm uh i'm in recovery from new
year's resolutions i had to quit i had
to quit them i was my new year's
resolutions would always be so intense
and extreme and just completely
unreasonable i remember one year i said
um
this is like when i mean i was i had
children i had like a full-time job a
life what was i thinking like i wanted
to read it was something like a hundred
and
like over a hundred books in a year like
two two a week i don't have that time
like i'm a decent reader but i'm not i'm
not that good of a reader so i realized
like and then i get um all of a sudden
my whole life
is sort of like frustrating me it's in
the way like my actual real life is in
the way of my goals that's when you know
you're going south like it's not good so
i no longer i don't really set new
year's resolutions i just try to live my
life good
maybe a little better this year that's
about that's my resolution so but the
lord bless you each of you if you've got
resolutions go for it i encourage you
it's uh but don't be too crazy don't get
too unreasonable with it
so we are um
let's see we're coming back we're coming
back to our a series this is if you're
with us um in the fall you'll be
familiar with
this book of first peter
and so we did chapter one in the past um
and now we kind of took a break of
course for advent and christmas and that
whole season and so now we're like back
back to first peter chapter two um and
each of these will be standalone
messages so don't um worry if you
weren't here you won't be like lost or
like what are they talking about
but to help kind of get everyone caught
up though i did want to
cover a little bit of just some
background of the book and this is
something if you were here in the fall
and the first message of for chapter one
we like covered some of these details um
so a little review for everyone since
it's been you know a few months um so
uh the author of the book of first peter
is peter
apostle of jesus makes sense um he's
writing
probably about the year you know 64 65
a.d somewhere in there which is um so
jesus was um crucified resurrected
descended in like 32 33 um 80. so you
know you're talking maybe 30ish years
after
um
christ kind of walk this earth
so um you know so you can tell this is
later in peter's life you know he's had
some years to reflect now this isn't
like young rambunctious always uh
you know kind of
saying things he can't really back up
and getting himself in trouble all the
time
this isn't that peter this is like old
kind of seasoned you know wise peter
so he's writing from rome
uh the audience location though he's
writing two people who were in what we
would call like modern day turkey sort
of asia minor
the their background so these are
gentile christians so remember peter of
course is if you know at all like the
gospels in the new testament you know
peter was jewish um which is why the
book is sort of shot through with a lot
of like old testament imagery and
language and things like that but his
audience um is not like they are
probably not familiar with like judaism
and all the you know the practices and
the rituals and the routines of that
life like that is not um the audience
these folks are probably coming from
just a diversity of like different
religious backgrounds and maybe even
cultural backgrounds uh so that's kind
of the the audience um
in terms of what they're like facing
they are facing in their context they're
facing some mild um persecution not like
you know you must die for the faith kind
of persecution but um you know probably
some job loss
um
there was it was just sort of frown the
christian faith was kind of new to the
area it was just kind of frowned upon
and sort of seen as suspect
so we kind of can pick up throughout the
book which ties in with some of the
themes
the uh so there's themes of discipleship
um you know how to be christ-like the
relationship of kind of christian faith
to the broader culture if you were here
for the first um part of this series you
know we touched on that a number of
times and we will continue because
that's like all throughout the book is
what does it mean to be a christian at
this particular place and at this
particular time and we often think like
well it's no problem it's just like you
know it's like american culture and
christian faith oh they're like two peas
in a pod you know
i don't know um peter doesn't think so
you know
so um you'll notice there's all this
language in fact i think it's the
message um
it's either next week or the one after i
always get confused because i'm like
writing you know different ones at
different times so i think it's one two
weeks from now where he goes back to the
whole your foreigners your strangers
your exiles your you know aliens in this
place it doesn't mean like from outer
space he means you know from the aliens
in terms of like from a different
country you know even though they're
literally not right they're not
literally from these different places
necessarily he's just saying to be
christian
is in a sense to be an alien and a
stranger in an exile even in your own
country
right so you can see the kind of
counter-cultural theme and he just keeps
coming back to this throughout um but
that's not the message you got to keep
going so um
and then the last thing was you know
trials temptation suffering things of
that nature which i think is quite
applicable
so um all right so that's some of the
background so tonight we're gonna kind
of focus in we're kicking off chapter
two so the title of my message is rid
in crave
rid and crave uh so we're going to be in
first peter chapter 2 verses 1 through 3
and it says this
therefore rid yourselves of all malice
and all deceit hypocrisy envy and
slander of every kind like newborn
babies crave pure spiritual milk so that
by it you may grow up in your salvation
now that you have tasted that the lord
is
good
so i like that peter opens with this
phrase um i mean it's sort of like he's
not asking questions here is he he's not
being very mousy either i mean even that
word rid yourselves right it's this i
like that it's sort of very emphatic you
know rid yourself like get rid of it
throw it away um toss it out um but the
actual words i think most of these we
know that kind of follow that that
phrase rid yourselves we're familiar
with that first one that's a little
strange anyone see that first one malice
rid yourselves of all malice like what
on earth is malice so malice evil
feelings
that take root in me
um and then kind of it's it's almost uh
an evil that kind of grows almost like a
cancer
you know like have you ever had like a
certain hatred or a venom in you
that um
boy it's like it started to
take over your life
right you ever thought you would kind of
compartmentalize the the evil like well
it's just this one part you know and
like slowly it just starts eating you up
and it's like you're getting becoming
more angry and more hateful and it's oh
gosh this that's malice and i think he
starts with that word probably because
it's very big picture you know sort of
all-encompassing um
uh a phrase you know malice rid
yourselves of all malice then he goes on
uh deceit getting my way via
manipulation and lies these were
probably more familiar with hypocrisy
pretending to be
what i'm not um envy hating the good in
another who they are or what they have
it's almost like if i can't have it i
don't want anyone to have it
even if it's a good thing like a good
thing in the world
you know we're like no
you know that's it's almost like hating
the good
um and then finally uh slander this of
course like speaking evil you know about
others behind their back back body and
things of that nature
now i'm not sure how this list strikes
you
um like i do think it's a kind of
relevant timely list in a way
um for our day and age and yet i don't
know how does it strike you like is it a
little bit um
kind of negative
maybe you're picking up it's like all
these words it's kind of intense right
just mal rid yourselves of all malice
it's just like oh my goodness like brett
is this so seriously this is how we're
starting the new year like here we go
first message uh because last week we
did you know kind of stories um
and this is our opening phrase you know
rid yourselves of all malice the evil
that grows in you like a cancer and it's
like oh my gosh and i can
i can kind of imagine it's almost this
um questions sometimes people have of
like i don't know why
why is the bible like this
you know like why
kind of come on
christianity and peter and you know like
why do you have to be it's so intense
and so um
i don't know it's just kind of it's just
so negative almost sad you know in a way
of like getting you to focus on all the
the negative things this probably isn't
like you know very tony robbins-esque
you know of like pump the people up you
know rid yourselves of all malice
probably he's never opened one of his
you know convention things with that and
it's just not very
you know what i'm talking about um
so i think having said that um i i don't
think the spirit of the text is i don't
think it's supposed to be just a beat
down of negativity and sadness
i don't think that's the like the spirit
of it so what i want to do is um kind of
help frame it or fill out the picture
by setting it alongside a quote and this
is from a christian writer
named anthony bloom
it's a wonderful wonderful quote he says
this as long as we ourselves are real
as long as we are truly ourselves god
can be present and can do something with
us but the moment we try to be what we
are not
there's nothing left to say or have we
become a fictitious personality in
unreal presence and this unreal presence
cannot be approached by god
interesting
um i love that that line specifically
kind of in the middle about um the
moment we try to be what we are not
i don't know about you but oh man that
is such a struggle
like do you find yourself kind of
tempted throughout the day to
sometimes we call it becoming the worst
version of ourselves
um
sometimes it's just well it's some of
the words from first peter
you know like hypocrisy it's it's
there's this
we just start pretending we start acting
from this place that's like
not who we really are
at least not who we um like not the
person god's called us to be in the one
that god knows
and made it's almost like this other
part to us that can just be like the
worst
um i have uh three kiddos
and um they're wonderful but they are
you know they're human beings so they're
just like
i don't know they're just normal like
they they have their issues you know
um i remember one time one sunday
finished preaching whatever and then uh
one of the our folks who attends the
table they were working in kids ministry
and it was their first i think first
sunday in kids ministry and one of them
came up to me and he was like he wasn't
trying to be you know mean or anything
but he kind of said in this kind of
funny voice he's like whoa so i watched
your uh one of your kids like
he's bad that's what he said he told me
that he's he's bad i was like well yeah
because they're human beings right and
like they're just not always perfect
angels um
but they are but they're good kids but i
do have one in particular right now um
maybe and if there's any parents you
know you can probably relate to they're
just like in a rough season
ever had the season just like i don't
know maybe you can't call it a season if
it goes on for two years
but i don't know at some point i just
gonna keep calling it a season and faith
that it will come to an end and it's
just like
you know it's just i don't know
they're just like in this place of um
of kind of insecurity you know kind of
trying to find
themselves but it's just
kind of coming out all i mean honestly
it comes across like super arrogant
that's just how it's sort of like put
everyone down
so that i can feel good
you know and um it just it pains me
partly we live in um you know our with
with our brother and sister-in-law
they're three kids um so it's sorry four
kids um we have the three they have the
four i get confused um
and so there's 11 people and so you know
there's something about kind of
parenting especially when the kids not
acting that's just not their angelic
season you know in front of others you
know that's that's that's a fun right
there's a lot of upsides to like
cohabitating living together supporting
each other this is one downside is when
your kid's in a rough season it's kind
of like
yeah you get to watch this that's great
and we're just trying to you know so
we're just kind of in the season
and insecure it's just kind of all i
mean i was reading the first peter list
you know i was like yeah that's a good
that's pretty that's a good description
you know kind of slander like just it's
sort of where this is just the season
they're in right just not their angelic
season now having said that apparently
according to their teacher
this kid's an angel
which is isn't that a bizarre thing how
it's like and thank i mean i'm not
complaining thank god for that like at
least we have that win and apparently in
public
this kid is doing better but um with us
you know just not their angelic season
um
until so we we had this this month we
had a long drive
over the holidays and uh it was
thanksgiving and about nine hours we're
driving out
and
this kid oh what happened i don't know
it was like this transformation took
place
um
they were like
kind
they were um kind of others focused like
building their siblings up encouraging
i mean it was
it was incredible it was almost like
just for this like nine hour window you
know i mean not five minutes but like
hours
of like it was like they were secure
they were just like the best version of
themselves and literally at one point my
wife maggie
turns to me and she's like
are you seeing this you know she's in
the passenger seat so they're all in the
back that's why i point this way are you
seeing this and i was like yes
and she's like this is amazing and she
said this is what i think is very wise
she said this is what we need to do
we need to keep naming
that this
this is who you really are
like that's what we said we need to name
like this this kiddo this one like kind
lifting others up building others up um
not so darn afraid
not so darn like just you know that
insecurity you're just trying to find
your place in the world and it's leaning
to the worst version of yourself like no
no we're not going that road like this
this
this is who you really
are
and so it's been you know that was
thanksgiving so a few weeks months
we've been trying like just doing our
best to keep naming like this kiddo like
no no not that
this this
is your true self this is who you really
are
kind loving patient
compassionate
this is who you are and i think in a way
of course i'm talking about my kiddo and
um
but in another level i'm talking about
all of us
right
because um
this this is us
you know
and um
i think there's even a difference though
i want to even clarify it's not even
just this is who you're called to be
you know because even that language can
kind of make it sound almost like uh i
think that's appropriate i do think it's
true like god does call us to be
you know who he made us to be like
that's true
but almost in that it kind of puts the
emphasis on um
almost like you know if you try real
hard
then you might become that person you
know what i mean which is slightly
different than than i think what anthony
bloom was naming
um which is no no
this is who you already are
right this is in you why because the
spirit of god
is present to each and every one of us
god created us he is the source of
everything like of who we are
and and so
um there there is this point within each
of us that is like god-centered
um
and i think deeply connected to christ
like always and already like this is our
always happening this is what um
in ephesians 4 22 through 24 paul calls
it the shift from the old self to the
new self
some people call it the shift from the
false self
to the true self
you know everyone has these kind of meta
these this language but hopefully you
you're kind of picking up on what it is
right that thing in each of us and
that's different than saying like hey
you need to become someone super
different than who you are
that's different right than no no
that's not who you are i think of
there's that line this is a super
outdated movie reference now so probably
no one will get it but if you've seen
twister
and there's that moment where he says
that was the old bill he's talking about
himself that was the old bill the evil
bill and i killed him
and uh right it's this sort of and i
think that's a little bit dramatic i'm
not saying okay you get it right it's
not in other words this part of us
right that just can go off the rails and
so the difference is i think paul's
naming hear peter's naming like no no
um this is who you really are
your true self you're christ centered
stuff like you are in christ this is who
you are
and i think that's why he says rid
yourselves
rid yourselves can you hear that it's
not just a a criticism of like hey
stop it because that's kind of the
negative part right it can sound just
kind of like hey stop it don't do that
no don't uh uh no no don't do it right
and that's how the list can kind of
strike at malice and slander yeah quit
all that you know which is that's
slightly different than
hey
those things just like to my kiddo right
those things like that's not who you
are
i know who you are
right not just who god's called you to
be but like i know who you are
and you need to step in to
that
i think um
in this sense you can tell that that
that whole list in verse one is not a
threat
right i think it's a reminder if you're
taking notes you can jot this down
becoming like christ
is the process of becoming who i truly
am
in other words who i truly always
already
was
which is why bloom says as long as we
ourselves are real as long as we are
truly ourselves like god can be present
to us
right god can do something with us but
the moment we try to be what we are not
like
that's when things fall apart another
way we might um say it is that leaving
sin behind
um this is not something that's like
unnatural extreme or crazy
but it's actually the highest sanity
right it is me becoming like precisely
who god always meant me to be
and and so this is why
um i think again it's not just a
criticism or a list of like all the bad
things you need to quit it get your life
together you know
but it's it's like hey
that's not who you are
so step in
step in a new direction which is why i
think he transitions from rid yourselves
verse one
and then what was the other word crave
rid yourselves and then crave you say
crava crave what verse two like newborn
babies crave pure spiritual milk
so that by it you may grow up in your
salvation
pure spiritual milk sort of a strange
metaphor um
what uh what is the pure spiritual milk
that's a good question and honestly as i
looked into this um depending on the
like commentator or theologian like
their own kind of theological background
they all answered it very differently
so i noticed that for example the
baptist all said of course
this
is the word of god which they meant in
scripture it's not just like jesus in
particular but they meant you know the
bible like that's the pure spiritual
milk of the word and there are other
verses in the bible kind of use the same
metaphor and refer to scripture um
and so that is kind of that slant and
then i noticed the um kind of the
calvinist reformed folks um they said
well what's the pure spiritual milk why
of course it is pure
doctrine
right the good orthodox teaching of the
faith
or i notice the
catholics they tend to say like the
eucharist right taking communion
um
the pentecostals
say like you know some sort of like
spiritual experience or prayer
um
the quakers
silence
the liberation theologians um caring for
the poor and the needy
all right this is when we're most
aligned this is when we're like really
connected to god and taken in the pure
spiritual milk is when we're like
serving the least of these you know
and um i think these are all really
fascinating answers and i do think
they're all on the right track i'm not
like listing them all to be like oh
those people are idiots you know like no
i think these are good things and i
think it's on the right track but it is
interesting that he actually says in uh
the following verse next verse first
three uh like he names it like what it
is verse three
now that you have tasted that the lord
is good
so who is the pure spiritual milk
it's god
god is the pure spiritual milk
and
what i think he's naming in this passage
is that there's a certain transformation
that takes place in us
that at first we're attempting to um
do a lot of ridding ourselves in the
christian life i think you know at the
church at its best is i think not a
museum for saints but a hospital for
sinners as someone once said and you can
kind of think of churches like a 12-step
program
you know it's like a place where we sort
of come together and we get real honest
and we're like yeah so um
i'm addicted to like all sorts of things
right the whole first peter list i'm
sort of an addict with like all of the
malice and the
anger and the hypocrisy and the like
right and this is sort of the community
of faith is not just in a negative sense
right and it's just some beat down way
but in an honest way
right it's sort of like yeah
we got issues and so this is what church
is right kind of all come together and
we're like yeah i've got some reading to
do i really i need some help here
um
[Music]
but
but we don't stop
there
and and so
but we start there
right so we're trying to heal we're
trying to become kind of unaddicted to
our fear unaddicted to our anger to our
malice to our envy to our hypocrisy
like all the things right we're trying
to we're kind of going down that road um
and then what happens is we start to get
glimpses
i think it's closest of our true self
right glimpses of
who god has meant us to be like glimpses
of peace
glimpses of patience
and kindness
joy
and it like you know at first it's not
like all the time we're not just
skipping through life you know just it's
wonderful but it's like we start to get
glimpses of this and we're like oh my
gosh hey
as i'm riding myself
something is happening
you know and then we start um some of
the things that the theologians were
talking about right maybe we start like
giving generously to people or we start
serving the poor or we begin you know
volunteering or um you know connecting
at church and worshiping or taking the
eucharist like a good catholic or you
know praying like a pentecostal or
sitting in silence like a quaker reading
that bible like a baptist i mean
whatever it is right but we start to
engage in these practices and we're like
oh my gosh
this is like working like i am feeling
a little more peace i am feeling a
little more patience i'm feeling a
little more kindness like this goodness
is kind of welling up in me
and someone then maybe talks to us and
is like so how have you been
experiencing god lately and you're like
buh well i haven't um but
i do like
all this stuff that's happening in me
and then maybe it's like months or years
later
it starts to dawn upon you
oh wait
so who is the source of every good
gift
is there any peace
that is not
like directly connected to god
is there any love
that is somehow
disconnected from the god who is love
is there like any patience or kindness
or goodness that's somehow
like a separate thing than god like
no and it dawns upon us oh my gosh
like the whole time i thought it was
about the thing like whatever my
tradition or my theologian or earth you
know kind of thing was
like i thought it was about the prayers
and saying in that certain way or that
practice of eucharist or worship or
whatever but like the whole time it was
actually god that i was getting a taste
for
it was god i was experiencing the way a
theologian named robert jensen lutheran
theologian he said um he said this like
when god gives a gift
is he like giving something other than
himself
or is he just
giving himself to you in a way that you
need and you experience it
as
fill in the blank right peace
joy love goodness kindness compassion
patience right
and i think it's a of course i don't
think god's like giving something
separate than himself like when god
gives a gift he gives the gift of
himself
and this is why i think um just to kind
of conclude that that the the church is
more than just a moralistic community
saying like clean yourselves up you know
rid yourselves get rid of all the malice
like come on people it's like okay
yeah we need to do that but
in the end we're like on a journey
towards god
like we're also
we're not just a
hospital for sinners
like also a mystical community like a
community of the holy spirit the spirit
of jesus
and we are on a journey
towards deep and profound connection
with the god who is love
and that's why peter says
at the end our goal is not just rid
yourselves then we like feel good about
ourselves but the end at the end it's
taste and see
that the lord is good
so
you might have noticed that as you came
in there was a small piece of paper and
the worship team can come up
a piece of paper in a pen for our local
people of course if you're online you
can grab a piece of paper and a pen or
just your phone whatever you got
and um we wanted to do is kind of kick
off the the new year with a little bit
of a kind of a practice or a response
um to the word that we've heard tonight
and so what i want to invite you to do
is just to name
um one thing that as you go into 2022
one thing you'd like to rid yourself of
this year
um and then
um one thing that you'd like to begin to
crave
and it could be um
you know whether you're naming like a
spiritual practice
you know like whether it's praying or
worship or something or um it could just
be a thing you need right like i need
peace this year
um i need joy this year whatever it is
and uh you can go ahead and just kind of
reflect on what that would be
and then um jot it down
as we as we worship for this last song
that sound good
cool
in the name of the father
and the son
and the holy spirit
amen
[Music]
come to the water
all who are thirsty
come and dream
[Music]
come to the table
[Applause]
those who are we
those who are needy
taste and see
[Music]
oh
to the water
all who are thirsty
[Music]
come and drink
come to the table
all who are hungry
come in
come to the river
let's sing that again
will
taste
and see that you are good
i
will taste
and see that you are good
and i will taste
you're good to
me
and i
will taste
and see that you are good
i
will taste
me
oh
you
are
come
to the water
all who are thirsty
come and dream
come to the table
all who are hungry
come in
[Music]
foreign
father would you uh
strengthen us this year the craving
for a greater revelation of the identity
of christ in each of us
that it would be understood within us
that it is no longer i will live the
christ that we might understand that
and that the real
me the real you
might come into agreement with one
another
father thank you for this message
tonight
thank you father that you have touched
our hearts and that you have opened in
us
father a craving once again
that true spiritual milk of the word
that milk that tells us and declares
with us that god is good and the giver
of everything good and perfect
i want to invite any of you that might
need prayer tonight to come up and be
happy to pray with you after the service
tonight
in fact i'd love to pray with you after
the service tonight i've been doing it
for 42 years so i'd love to do it again
tonight praise god
i
want to remind you once again about the
meetup that begins tonight for the
teenagers uh right after the service
well it says it's 6 45 so i guess that's
about right after the service
and then also want to ask you as
visitors if you're a visitor here
tonight uh i want to go back to that
card in the little box right outside the
door here the one that says uh
what's the name of this church pleasant
valley church on it
use that card and if you have a desire
to
learn more about the church or hear
directly from the pastors uh in a more
intimate way rather than just sitting
here
but
put the information on the card put that
in there and also again if you have
interest in joining yourself to a meetup
group
please put that information in that
little box that's out there
and
i'm going to ask you to do this if you
would stand with me
[Music]
and
i'm going to
place a stream of benediction right
alongside the beautiful benediction that
karen brings us so often
reminding us that we are children of god
on our best days
and on our worst days
and so i'd like for you to just close
your eyes and just hold out your hands
to receive this and i want you to listen
carefully to this
as i said it's just a stream
saying much the same of what she's
saying to us
you are included
forever included
not by any religious affiliation
not by affiliation with christianity are
you included but you are forever
included
not by confession of any creed
not by personal profession of faith
[Music]
not by an altar or a baptistery
experience
nor by having read the book
[Music]
or continuing to read the book
you are included not by the life you
have
lived not by the life you now live
nor by the life that you have yet to
live
but you are included forever included
only and always by the predetermined
will and purpose of the father creator
before time began
a will and a purpose that does not
demand human response
let me say that again
you are included by a will and a purpose
that does not
place a demand upon you for human
response
nor does it require human knowledge
these are the words of apostle paul
god has saved us and called us
with a holy calling not
according to our works
those things that i've read were
some of the works that we have
thought include caused us to be included
but according to his own
purpose and grace
which was given to us in christ jesus
before time began
but has now been revealed by the
appearing of our savior jesus christ
who has abolished death and brought life
and immortality to light through the
gospel
[Music]
so in conclusion the gospel
the gospel the true gospel
is all men's inclusion it's the
revelation of your inclusion
from before time began
the incarnation is humanity's inclusion
[Music]
the revelation of jesus is the
revelation that all mankind has been
included from before time began
father i just
ask you to just open up in the
understanding of each and every one
[Music]
the height and the depth and the breadth
and the width
of your all-inclusive love
that no longer would we stand in
judgment of ourselves
no longer would we see ourselves at any
time excluded from the grace and the
purpose and the mercy of god
no longer will we look outside of our
affiliations
and judge those to be excluded
because of their religious affiliation
because of any lifestyle that they're
living within
because of any cr any creed that is
contrary to our creed or in disagreement
with our creed
for whatever reason father
allow our hearts to be opened up
to understand that you are inclusion
that's all you've ever been that's all
you'll ever be is the inclusion
of this humanity that you have created
to be yours forevermore
ask these things in jesus name amen
praise god
you are dismissed
[Music]
you